في جامعة محمد بن راشد
للطب والعلوم الصحية ،
أطلقنا أول برنامج لزراعة الكلى
في دبي بالتعاون مع
عيادة ميديكال كلينيك ومستشفى مدينة الجزائر ومستشفى الأطفال في الجزائر.
عملية جراحية كبيرة
وطواعية والمخاطرة
بحياتهم لإنقاذ حياة أحبائهم ،
لذلك من واجبنا أن نمنحهم
أكثر
الآثار الجانبية أمانًا
حتى يتمكنوا من العودة إلى الحياة الطبيعية.الجراحة
الروبوتية لها شق أصغر
به
منافذ صغيرة مثل الروبوت  تتمتع الذراعين
بمرونة أكثر من
اليد والجراح الذي يكون بعيدًا عن
المريض الجالس على وحدة التحكم لديه رؤية ثلاثية الأبعاد
ومكبر حجمًا ، مما يجعل الجراحة
أكثر دقة ونزيفًا أقل
مضاعفات
[الموسيقى]
في الواقع ما يهتمون به  هو
العودة إلى طبيعتها ويمكننا إجراء عملية
جراحية لا تقطع العضلات
التي يمكنهم العودة إليها في غضون
أسبوعين  شخصًا بعيدًا من قبل
يمكنه فعل كل ما يفعله بشكل طبيعي
دون قيود ، وهذا ما نبحث عنه
هو ما أنشأناه هو
ما طورته سموك
وهو هيكل
الأكاديميين الذين
يقدمون الرعاية الصحية والأبحاث التي هي
البنية التحتية
الآن من هناك ، أتيت  عندما
أبدأ بالكلى ، فنحن الآن نؤسس هذا
بكل ما هو محدد لذلك ، ثم نذهب إلى
معرض الكبد
في نفس الوقت بالكبد نبدأ
في النظر إلى القلوب لدينا الناس
هنا يمكنهم القيام بذلك والأهم هو
واسع  البنية التحتية هي تعليم كل
مجتمعنا
أن زراعة الأعضاء بالتبرع هي
جزء من الرعاية الصحية إنها جزء مما نقوم
به ، إنها ليست معجزة حدثت هنا
وتبدو جيدة في الأخبار ، إنها
تتعلق بما يجب أن نفعله
لرعاية المرضى بشكل نهائي  - مرض عضو المرحلة